[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires voici les
titres de l'actualité
l'ouverture des commerces la réouverture
des commerces avec les annonces du
président de la république la france
souffle de nouveau ses commerces vont
pouvoir ouvrir leurs portes
emmanuel macron a annoncé un plan en
trois étapes d'ici au 15 janvier
on y revient dans un instant là cinq
jeux dans les territoires c'est un débat
qui a animé de nombreuses réunions dans
nos régions
la 5g toutes les questions qui entourent
son implantation avec les opérateurs de
téléphonie qui cherche un consensus
souvent difficiles à trouver nous vous
en parlons dans ce journal
autre titre la plate forme solidaire en
nouvelles aquitaine où l' agence de
l'alimentation avait mis en place une
plate forme solidaire depuis mars
dernier pour permettre aux producteurs
de la région de trouver des débouchés
pour leurs produits de saison vous le
verrez le succès est au rendez vous
enfin nous découvrirons ensemble ce qui
pourrait devenir le plus bel arbre de
l'année 2020 un cèdre bleu de la classe
qui est qualifié pour ce concours
national nous verrons ça en fin de
journal
enfin une bonne nouvelle pour démarrer
ce journal les commerçants vont pouvoir
ré ouvrir leurs portes cette semaine
de quoi réjouir ces commerçants bien
entendu mais également les clients comme
vous et moi
écoutez ces quelques réactions
enregistrées à epinal dans les vosges
oui freha mois d'attentes
non non c'est non conséquent heureux
samedi voilà je pense que tout le monde
était pressé et les ça fait du bien de
revenir mais savoir qu'on peut rouvrir
déjà beaucoup de préparatifs le retour
ben de ce qu'on n'a pas vendu
après on reçoit la nouvelle collection
donc pour mettre en place et puis ma
changement de tous tout le magasin est
préparé aussi avant les fêtes quoi alors
c'était plutôt une très bonne nouvelle
pour nous les coiffeurs les
esthéticiennes parce qu'on attendait
cette date vraiment avec impatience on
était tous en zoom avec des équipes en
disant croisons les doigts pour qu on
résoudre cette semaine là maintenant
c'est toute une organisation avec les
rendez-vous parce qu'en fait avec le
nouveau les nouvelles réglementations
1 dispose de huit mètres carrés par par
client donc c'est deux fois plus de
place donc deux fois plus deux fois
moins de clients
bon ça va être compliqué ce sont
vraiment des laissait vraiment par les
mesures qui sont prises comme on l'avait
expliqué ben moi ça fait quatre mois
j'ai quatre mois d'existence et c'est
très dur c'est très dur en tant que
jeune restaurateur autre réaction cette
fois qu'ils sont bien entendu moins
positive celle des stations de ski
vous savez le président de la république
a laissé entendre qu'elle ne pourrait
pas être ouvertes pour les fêtes
une concertation a lieu en ce moment
même voici leurs réactions au micro de 8
mont blanc nos confrères sur place à
courchevel cela faisait déjà quelques
semaines que les professionnels de la
montagne se préparer à une réouverture
prochaine
suspendu à l'allocution d'emmanuel
macron pascal deux tiers son directeur
de la société des trois vallées découvre
en même temps que plusieurs millions de
français
les nouvelles annonces mais après
quelques minutes c'est un coup de massue
les stations ne devrait pas rouvrir
avant mi janvier
c'est la douche froide parce que on a on
a fait que ce soit au niveau de
l'entreprise au niveau de la sté station
on a beaucoup travaillé pour pouvoir
justement proposer des protocoles
proposer des façons de travailler qui
soit compatible avec une ouverture à
noël est aujourd'hui à travers les mots
du président on sent que
c'est peut-être pas le cas au lendemain
des annonces les commerçants eux aussi
sont amers après une courte nuit passée
à réfléchir à une réorganisation de son
activité
patrick le peu de riz gérant de
plusieurs boutiques à courchevel et
représentants des commerçants a tenu à
réunir ses employés ce matin c'est un
sentiment d'injustice qui l'animent
sentir qu'on est les seuls à rester
fermés alors que toutes les autres
activités vont être ouvertes des
activités où les gens vont se retrouver
bien plus confiné bien plus les uns des
uns avec les autres
leurs montagnes où les gens sont sur les
pistes sont loin les uns des autres
ça fait effectivement très très mal oui
un peu plus haut col de la lauze ce
restaurateur est lui aussi des ens paris
s'il ne s'attendait pas à réouvrir son
restaurant il espérait toutefois une
ouverture prochaine de la station il
avait d'ailleurs réfléchit à des offres
de pique nique à emporter le gros la
saison est foutue sachant quand même que
le mois de décembre c'est une grosse
partie c'est déjà une trésorerie qui
entraîne sur mettre en place pour nous
c'est c'est pratiquement va à rennes
c'est important de la saison
les professionnels de la montagne espère
désormais que des négociations avec le
gouvernement seront possibles il compte
désormais sur la deuxième partie de la
saison pour rattraper ses pertes
économiques
le président de la république toujours
lui qui a mis en garde les français sur
les rassemblements durant ces périodes
de fêtes et de fin d'année à noël pas
comme les autres pour les artisans
chocolatiers notamment qui profitent
d'ordinaire de cette période pour
réaliser la majorité de leur chiffre
d'affaires
déjà mise à mal lors du premier
confinement avec l'absence de pâques
vous l'aviez constater ce nouveau
ralentissement de l'économie pourraient
être dramatiques chez certains comme
nous le montre ce reportage de michel
weiss pour moselle télévision
malgré le confinement fabrice du mais ne
s'est jamais arrêté dans sa boutique de
marle il continue à fabriquer du
chocolat sous toutes ses formes métal
approche de la saint nicolas
il y a un produit qui porte toute son
attention car ils s'apprêtent à mouler
entre 3 et 4000 pièces de la star du
moment
le saint patron des écoliers on a refusé
quelques grands voiliers ont fait
toujours sous à la main et c'est des
commandes de dernière minute alors
c'était des c'était des grosses demandes
c'était des demandes de 1000 pièces et
on n'a que dix moules en fait donc c'est
relativement longs à fabriquer s'il fait
l'impasse ici sur une grosse commande
pour favoriser ses clients il sait
pertinemment que ce sont les entreprises
et qu'il est à rester à flot lors de
cette période extrêmement complexe en
fournissant près d'une centaine de
clients aux quatre coins de france
il compense quelque peu les pertes liées
à la diminution de ses fidèles gourmands
une baisse qu'il estime à près de 30%
mais tous n'ont malheureusement pas
cette chance quelques kilomètres plus
loin mais cela polonaise n'est ouverte
que le week end
la production est donc réduite comme les
clients ne sont pas au rendez vous ce
matin là philippe maes est affairé une
tâche qu'il n'aurait jamais imaginé
devoir réalisé il ya quelques mois
mettre en avant ses produits sur
internet grâce au click and collect
philippe maes y consacre beaucoup de
temps et d'énergie pour peu de résultats
déjà en difficulté lors du premier
confinement ce nouveau ralentissement de
l'économie lui a déjà fait perdre près
de 70% de son chiffre d'affaires une
situation qui devrait si elle perdure
menace est très sérieusement son
activité ou pâques et noël c'est ce qui
nous fait vivre tout le reste de l'année
le reste de l'année on
on tient le coup mais grâce à la
trésorerie qu'on engrange sur les deux
grosses fêtes là surtout quand on est
quand on entend du chocolat mais là
c'est non là c'est catastrophique
si on fait par un noël normal je ne peux
rien dire pour 2021 c'est pas dit qu'on
n'ouvre la porte
tous espèrent malgré tout une
amélioration de la situation le 1er
décembre prochain
sauvé la période des fêtes sera donc
déterminante pour l'économie de ces
artisans à plus forte raison lorsque
l'on sait que plus de 30 mille tonnes de
chocolat sont vendus en france chaque
année
[Musique]
voilà parlons à présent des conséquences
du confinement sur les agriculteurs nous
nous rendons dans les vosges à la
rencontre des propriétaires d'une
entreprise emc2 une coopérative plus
précisément spécialisé dans les bovins
pour cette entreprise du grand est
l'espoir est de ne laisser personne sur
le bord du chemin
un reportage d'une équipe devient vosges
dans une exploitation touchés par la
crise près de vittel regarder
une visite au moins une fois par mois
cette exploitation dans la plaine des
vosges est suivi de près par une
coopérative régionale qui doit faire
face tout comme les éleveurs à une
situation inédite la filière de la
viande bovine est très impacté par la
crise sanitaire notamment par la
fermeture des restaurants
ça fait dix ans que la coopérative non
je n'avais jamais connu ce genre de
problème c'était plutôt on va dire
fluide
certain nombre d'animaux en particulier
les jeunes bovins que l'on à la perte de
leur valeur au 24ème mois de leurs
animaux leur date d'anniversaire
donc on a mis en place une logistique
pour permettre de ramasser les animaux
qui risquait de passer l'âge fatidique
ces jeunes bovins parts au compte
gouttes au lieu d'être gérés en lots
habituellement ce qui engendre des
surcoûts de transport et logistique
surcoût également et surtout pour les
éleveurs ça a des conséquences quand
même importante sur les exploitations
parce que le fait de garder les animaux
plus longtemps donc ça consomme de
l'alimentation faut savoir que dans les
régions dans nos régions on est à la
troisième quatrième ou quatrième année
de sécheresse donc complètement imputé
nos stocks aujourd'hui on est sur des
sommes vraiment limite
la deuxième conséquence et la trésorerie
des exploitations parce que plus vous
attendez pour faire partir une avance de
trésorerie à taux zéro a été mise en
place par la coopérative e mc2 pour
soutenir la filière qui vit aussi grâce
à belo contractualiser avec des
restaurants de fast-food riba
difficultés d'écoulement la filière
souffre mais concentre ses efforts sur
la production d'une viande de moins en
moins destinés à l'export
les grandes surfaces ont semble-t-il
saisi le message du soutien aux éleveurs
français mais d'autres territoires
restent à conquérir les cantines
scolaires avance bien vers une
consommation plus local plus française
mais il ya encore plein d'autres pans
d'activités l'armée les hôpitaux les
maisons de retraite qui pourraient
consommer encore plus français que la
relance de la filière qui passera donc
aussi par les choix de consommation de
chacun une fois la crise sanitaire
terminer je vous le disais dans les
titres lagence de l'alimentation
nouvelle aquitaine avait mis en place
une plate forme solidaire pour permettre
aux producteurs de la région de trouver
des débouchés pour leurs produits de
saison comme les fraises ou les asperges
et aux habitants bien sûr de consommer
local et c'est un grand succès puisque
quatre cent mille personnes se sont
connectées sur ce site
regardez les explications de tv7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest sur place né
en 1963 la sica me richer d'easynet une
coopérative de dix producteurs de fruits
et légumes du nord ouest de la métropole
mais elle commercialise la production
d'une quarantaine d'autres producteurs
des départements les mains
prof essentiellement auprès de la grande
distribution mais depuis une quinzaine
d'années elle a développé la vente aux
particuliers notamment sous forme de
livraison de paniers une activité
amplifiée par le confinement son
inscription dès le mois de mars sur la
plate forme solidaire de l'anah lui a
permis de mieux se faire connaître et
d'attirer de nouveaux consommateurs
tôt ce mois soit le plus haut
pourcentage non répartis sur novembre
cette année on va faire autour de 18 ou
20 % que de 22 directeur
qu'habituellement on tournait autour
d'eux
petite dizaine de pour cent mille huit
cents producteurs sont aujourd'hui
accessibles sur cette plateforme
dans toute la région à partir de votre
géolocalisation vous allez avoir autour
de vous les producteurs avec les
produits qui vous livre où vous pouvez
retirer des produits dans les points de
retrait si le succès de la plateforme
est un peu retombé à la fin du premier
confinement elle reprend aujourd'hui du
service avec quelques nouveautés
l'offre s'est largement amélioré et on
vient d'ouvrir la plateforme aux
restaurateurs pour les aider parce que
je pense qu'ils vont être fermés assez
longtemps et tous les restaurateurs qui
proposent des produits en livraison ou
en cliquant collecte pourront s'inscrire
sur la plateforme ça va les aider ça
peut les aider
ça fera pas tout mais je pense que les
gens seront sensibles à ça aussi
autre titre dans l'actualité ces
dernières semaines les associations
environnementales ont mobilisé les
citoyens pour qu'ils nettoient leurs
kilomètres
il est simple profiter des balades
autorisé d'un kilomètre dans son secteur
pour ouvrir l'oeil et ramasser tout ce
qui traîne maintenant d'ailleurs ça va
être 20 km direction lanester en
bretagne où xavier patrigeon de la
chaîne tébéo a suivi une famille
regarder des actes poubelle un râteau et
des gants cette famille lanestérienne
est prête à relever le débit d'eau et
rivières de bretagne jusqu'au 29
novembre l'association incite les
citoyens à ouvrir l'oeil et à nettoyer
son km durant les balades autorisée ça
s'inscrit dans la semaine de réduction
européenne de réduction des déchets donc
l'idée c'est aussi de proposer aux gens
de dalé pendant un kilomètre sortir
autour de chez eux et et voir les
déchets qu'ils trouvaient finalement on
se rend compte que on peut facilement
trouver beaucoup plus de déchets que ce
qu'on pensait enfin là par exemple ce
matin
vu tout ce qu on a ramassé on pensait
même pas en partant empirait autant de
ce à quoi une sortie qui mêle donc
l'utile à l'agréable
c'est super on fait sortir papa maman
entre ballades un peu
et puis se rendent compte ainsi que viol
auquel il ya plein de déchets
l'initiative se prête plutôt bien à
cette période de confinement pour
l'occasion on peut envoyer la photo de
sa collecte à l'association l'idéal
serait de continuer tout au long de
l'année
ou pourquoi pas même de ne plus jeter
ses déchets n'importe où voilà comme
dans chaque grand jt des territoires
place à la rubrique écorégions nous
allons nous intéresser à une initiative
dans les territoires on va parler de la
marque consommateurs
c'est qui le patron c'est un succès
français colossal bonjour michel picaud
alors c'est qui le patron
cette marque est née dans le vaucluse et
lance cette semaine son application
mobile
bonjour vous reconnaissez certainement
cette fameuse brique de lait je voulais
justement vous en parler aujourd'hui
c'est une vraie fierté française qui
s'est beaucoup développée en europe et
même aux états unis
le visuel de c'est qui le patron vous le
connaissez le concept est extrêmement
nouveau même s'il a été lancée il ya
quatre ans et pourtant il a déjà battu
des records de vente il s'agit de lait
de beurre of steak pizza bref il ya
aujourd'hui 150 produits différents en
vente en 2017 ils ont commencé par le
lait il espérait en vendre 5 millions de
briques la première année ils en ont
vendu 35 millions en 2020 205 millions
de produits c'est qui le patron déjà été
vendus alors qu'ils ne font aucune
publicité
alors ce succès c'est d'abord un concept
ce sont les consommateurs plus de 10000
qui par internet fixe le prix du produit
afin d'offrir une rémunération plus
juste producteurs donc ils sont prêts à
payer plus cher mais ils veulent des
contreparties comme par exemple pas
d'eau gm des vaches qui vivent plus
longtemps en plein air une alimentation
saine pour les animaux ce ne sont que
quelques exemples et le producteur est
régulièrement contrôlé sur ses
engagements pour rappel avant la crise
de grands groupes industriels acheter
encore et c'est un peu le cas le litre
de lait entre 32 et 34 centimes
ils coûtent à produire 36 centimes dont
qu'il produisait du lait à perte
tout cela pour avoir des prix dont
supermarché pour vous et moi qui faisons
nos courses chez c'est qui le patron on
achète le lait 40 à 42 centimes le litre
le producteur peut en vivre et même
partir en vacances
merci michel picaud rendez vous dans un
prochain grand jt des territoires pour
une nouvelle rubrique éco région voilà
un coup de coeur maintenant dans le
grand jt des territoires ce coup de
coeur nous vient d'occitanie grâce
hamilton d'habitude coiffure en salon
qui a décidé de venir donner un coup de
peigne aux sans abri il s'est installé
sur la place de la comédie à montpellier
ce coiffeur qui est aussi un influenceur
espère qu'il pourra inspirer d'autres
personnes à venir aider les sans abri un
reportage de nos confrères sur place
devient occitanie regardez c'est le
genre d'initiative qui fait chaud au
coeur
milton d'habitude coiffeur en salle on a
décidé de venir donner un coup de peigne
aux sans abri il s'est installé ce week
end place de la comédie à montpellier
voilà du coup sûr tout mon matériel jugé
les droits de folique et la lotion
désinfectante maison la même prestation
qu'en salon les volontaires ne manquent
pas et c'est christophe 48 ans qui
s'aventurent en premier plus court vers
l'avant comme ça christophe qui n'a pas
eu l'occasion de se faire couper les
cheveux depuis six mois bien droite y en
avoir un
qui d'entre nous qui parle avec nous et
de nous
save au touch les deux salons de 1000
tonnes sont actuellement fermés il a
voulu profiter du confinement pour venir
aider les plus fragiles
le fait qu'on soit confiné et qu'on soit
un peu tard mais dans la merde là j'ai
préféré décidé d'aller voir des
personnes qu'ils sont dans la merde tous
les jours qu'il fasse chaud froid et que
personne s'en occupe deux personnes
apportent d'intérêt il faut compter un
quart d'heure la coupe
visiblement le résultat fait des heureux
c'est génial jamais joué à neuf mais non
voilà vous trouvez tout beau comme
christophe mille tonnes à couper 10
personnes ce dimanche après midi
ce coiffeur aussi influenceurs espère
qu'il pourra inspirer d'autres personnes
à venir aider les sans abri dans ce
contexte difficile pour tous c'était
cette semaine la campagne de ré
ouverture des restos du coeur avec vous
savez de nombreux demandeurs dans toute
la france qui sont en attente
nous allons d'ailleurs le voir avec ce
reportage tourné par caroline fichten de
nos confrères de wéo la chaîne de la
voix du nord direction couderc dans le
nord regardez ce reportage
pas si facile quand espace sur le
trottoir est restreint de respecter la
distanciation social pour autant ici à
coudekerque-branche près de dunkerque
pour ce premier jour de campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur on s'adapte il a
fallu faire quelques aménagements mais
rien d'insurmontable
ici il rentre à la fois que quatre
personnes au maximum quatre personnes
qui peuvent rentrer à la fois ici
d'habitude ya plus de monde là les gens
dans ce centre lors de la dernière
campagne des restos près de 250 familles
étaient suivis ici comme partout
ailleurs les bénévoles s'attendent à une
hausse des inscriptions notamment à
cause de la crise sanitaire
on a bien entre 10 à 15 % voire plus
de famille alors supplémentaires c'est
vrai qu'on a des personnes nakba
justement convient d'inscrire les gens
qui accueille coville un nom n'en pas
retrouvé des intérimaires qui n'ont pas
retrouvé leur emploi dès situation
financière compliquée qui oblige
certains foyers a poussé pour la
première fois la porte des restos on
trouve donc ici une aide alimentaire
certes mais aussi un accueil et du
contact sur le littoral et le dos marois
14000 personnes bénéficient de l'aide
des restos du coeur
ça représente plus d'un million et demi
de repas vous le savez peut-être cette
semaine c'est la ville de nice qui a été
la première à lancer cette nouvelle
technologie de 5 g depuis quelques jours
les opérateurs se lancent à l'assaut des
autres territoires
entre temps la population souhaite
lancer des débats un peu partout sur
cette nouvelle technologie qui fait
parfois peur
direction la roche la molière et
saint-aignan dans la loire où nos
confrères de tl7 ont assisté à ces
rencontres regarder dans ce quartier de
roche-la-molière des pancartes
fleurissent dans les jardins elle
dénonce l'installation prochaine d'une
antenne 5g sur ce terrain privé à
quelques mètres des habitations jérôme
tout est responsable informatique depuis
25 ans ils s'inquiètent des conséquences
de la 5g sur la santé une école de 100 m
une autre antenne qui est 300 ou 400 m
si compte tenu qu'il faut des antennes
de plus en plus rapprochées pour la 5g
il va y avoir des antennes de partout et
on voudrait savoir vraiment s'il n'y a
pas de danger
et aujourd'hui on n'en sait rien au mois
d'août l'opérateur téléphonique a pris
contact avec la mairie
c'est obligatoire pour chaque antenne on
appelle ça un dossier d'information du
maire mais il ne peut pas refuser le
permis de construire ou en auront refusé
que ce soit sur les terrains communaux
et dès qu'un propriétaire privé signe un
contrat avec un opérateur
moi j'en vois immédiatement un courrier
aux riverains pour leur signaler qu'il
ya quelque chose qui se fait depuis son
jardin emilie a vu sur ce pylône son
collectif rassemble une trentaine
d'habitants elle espère que l'antenne ne
mettra jamais au départ on nous a bien
dit que l'installation de l'antenne
c'était en 4g voilà aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas on n'a pas d'information sur ce
sujet donc on est un voile en attente
est-ce que la 5g ne sera pas finalement
la prochaine crise sanitaire
voilà aujourd'hui on a le lac au vide
mais peut-être que dans 5 10 ans sera
peut-être la prochaine crise sanitaire
d'ici 2022 les opérateurs doivent
implanté 3000 nouveaux pylônes en france
dans le cadre du développement de la 5g
les propriétaires de terrains sollicité
toucherait entre 7000 et 15000 euros par
an nous partons en normandie maintenant
plus précisément à dieppe pour le projet
de construction d'un centre
océanographique qui se poursuit avec une
ouverture prévue en 2023 au grand public
il deviendra l'un des plus grands
d'europe et le futur aquarium normands
se mobilisent dès à présent pour la
sauvegarde des espèces en signant des
conventions pour restauration des
ressources naturelles lcn la chaîne
normande nous présente ce projet à
regarder
la société aqua invest assure avoir reçu
toutes les autorisations pour envisager
la construction d'un centre
océanographique à dieppe en normandie
avec les livraisons en 2023 d'un
bâtiment de haute qualité
environnementale le centre
océanographique de dieppe état est un
projet environnemental dans sa
conception dans sa philosophie c'est un
projet de territoire
et quand on parle de développement
durable on essaie effectivement de
focaliser autour de ce site de façon à
créer des interactions humaines
techniques et bien sûr liée à la
transition écologique
les clients auront la possibilité de
voir un élément phare du site qui sera
la fosse à plongée de plus de 50 mètres
quelques chiffres donc on sera sur dix
sept mille mètres carrés on pourra y
voir mes 400 espèces aquatiques des
différentes des différents océans des
maires des lacs et des rivières cet
aquarium va présenter des espèces qui
serait né qui seront élevés aux
philippines
comment faire grossir à dieppe pour
ensuite peuple et ce bassin et ce bassin
sera une image au sein de notre site de
ce que fait l'action de les clés sous
quels sont les résultats de l'action
scientifiques sur le terrain le but
c'est de participer à la présente
préservation des espèces
les promoteurs du centre océanographique
de dieppe évalué l'investissement à 80
millions d'euros 70 emplois directs et
espère plus de cinq cent mille visiteurs
chaque année
je vous disais dans les titres on prend
la direction de montée sont maintenant
dans les yvelines où un arbre de cette
commune pourrait devenir le plus bel
arbre de l'année 2020 déjà lauréat en
ile de france c'est un cèdre bleu de
l'atlas qui est qualifié pour le
concours national
il a été planté il y à 90 ans dans le
centre hospitalier théophile roussel et
a vu défiler évidemment des générations
et des générations d'enfants
un reportage de michael elle me doro et
de romain rouy spinney pour tv 78
regarder il est en course pour devenir
l'arbre de l'année 2020 ce cèdre bleu de
l'atlas enraciné dans le centre
hospitalier théophile roussel de
montesson fait partie des quatorze
finalistes nationaux
cet arbre qui mesure 12 mètres d'eau a
été planté avant la seconde guerre
mondiale dans le parc de cette ancienne
maison de correction pour garçons il a
vu passer des générations d'enfants en
90 ans d'existence
ils ont profité de cet art où ils ont vu
cet arbre ils ont sûrement confier des
secrets ils ont grimpé dans l'arbre
c'est un lieu de vie de passage voilà
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a lancé dans cette
aventure du concours de l'arbre de
l'année
cette histoire a séduit le jury
aujourd'hui le site est devenu un
établissement de santé mentale et
l'arbre a vu les années défilent et il
porte sur son tronc et ses branches les
stigmates du temps conséquences du gel
et des sécheresses d'une mini tornade en
encore de la fameuse tempête de 1999 a
perdu au moins cinq matches au niveau de
la sim
quand il ya eu la tempête est donc
maintenant son mât 12 mètres 50 au lieu
de dire presque 18 mètres qui lave au
départ avec une circonférence que l'on a
pu mesurer que les salissent techniques
et espaces verts de trois mètres
cinquante de circonférence
le cèdre bleu compte à ce jour plus de
1250 signature il est pour l'instant
sixième position sur 14
si vous voulez le soutenir vous pouvez
voter jusqu'au 5 janvier
voilà et puis je signale dans la
rubrique médias des territoires cette
opération du courrier picard qui aura
lieu le 3 décembre prochain une
opération liées à la crise sanitaire qui
bien sûr remet en cause tout
l'écosystème oblige les économies à se
réinventer et même à anticiper le monde
d'après et bien que les picards réunira
les décideurs les organisations
syndicales qui se mobilisent
pour aider les entreprises à rebondir et
à repenser l'économie de demain ce jeudi
3 décembre une table ronde
exceptionnelle sera organisée par les
équipes de mickaël tassart
le rédacteur en chef du courrier picard
à l'issue de laquelle vous pourrez poser
toutes vos questions toutes ces
informations sont à retrouver sur
courrier picard point fr il y aura des
représentants du medef de la cpm de la
cci d'amiens picardie de la chambre des
métiers et de l'artisanat ainsi que
l'économiste jacques de larosière et le
président de la région des routes france
xavier bertrand lors de ce grand débat
sur ce thème réinventer l'économie
rendre les entreprises plus agile voilà
saluons cette opération du courrier
picard
partenaire du grand jt des territoires
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de nous
avoir suivi sur aux chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde
le grand jt des territoires en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale
merci à tous et à très vite en voir
[Musique]